arrivé presque à leur destination à 7h30
ce matin un véhicule de transport adapté
pour deux élèves de 15 ans en 3e segpa
au collège des hôtels à charolles dévie
de sa route et entre en collision avec
un car régionales la conductrice une
femme de 45 ans meurt sur le coup ainsi
que le passager arrière du véhicule le
passager avant est toujours entre la vie
et la mort au chu de lyon pour le maire
de la ville
c'est un nouveau drame sur la rcea un
jeune avait déjà perdu la vie il y a
quelques mois pratiquement au même
endroit
cette route même sans les les travaux
elle est dangereuse
le nombre de morts qu'il ya eu sur cette
route se comptent par dizaines
et ce n'était plus tenable c'est un
grand sentiment d'insatisfaction mais
aujourd'hui j'ai un sentiment de
tristesse et est presque de de lassitude
l'accident s'est passé à l'entrée ouest
de charolles dans un secteur en travaux
jusqu'à la fin 2019 et où la vitesse
passe rapidement de 70 à 50 km heure il
implique donc une vigilance renforcée
des automobilistes avec cet accident on
a déploré 34 morts depuis le début de
l'année 2018 sur le département
donc maintenant trois personnes décédées
sur les rangs je ne crois pas que ce
soit un lieu plus risqués la vitesse a
été adapté justement pour tenir compte
de cette situation on est sur une voie
de déviation liés en effet aux travaux
mais voilà il ya un des panneaux qui
signalent parfaitement la voie réduite
au néant
en bidirectionnel donc ce qui nécessite
de la part des conducteurs un
comportement adapté en terme de vitesse
ce drame a été annoncée à 10 heures ce
matin aux enseignants et aux élèves de
3e segpa
les cours qui devait suivre ont été
annulés demain une minute de silence
sera observée pour l'élève et la
conductrice décédée et une cellule
psychologique sera mise en place